[Music]
let's go out to anthony in kansas city
missouri what's up anthony
uh what's going on how you doing we're
doing all right brother how are you
i'm pretty good it's hot over here so
it is cool making its way across the
country here so what's up dude how can
we help
hey i was just calling today because i'm
trying to get some advice on starting a
budget trying to get out of debt um i
don't have any
clue on where to start
i downloaded the every dollar app and
still don't know
where to start on anything so
all right starting from scratch
so anthony yeah so um
what what's what is your situation how
much debt do you have do you have any
savings kind of where you at
um i don't have any savings i don't have
anything like i i own my mobile home
um i'm about i would say about
15 000 in debt
okay i'm including my car
is that car credit card student loans
um it's
more like hospital bills
okay and
like some cell phone service stuff okay
and how much do you make a year
uh 31 000 okay yeah what do you do
um i do have a forklift for
for hostess actually okay yeah yeah
awesome okay
well anthony i mean yeah i think one of
the best starting places and what you
did which is great is is the budgeting
um when you do a budget there is this
level of feeling completely in control
of your money and for you maybe for the
first time ever where you're thinking oh
gosh you know i don't know i'm getting
my paycheck in i have no clue where it's
going and so what you want to do is you
want to do it before the month begins so
we're here in july right now the
beginning of july so you could even say
i'm going to start this in august so
august 1
and you're going to look at your budget
for august you're going to look at your
expenses everything from your yeah if
you have a payment on the mobile home
to electricity water
uh food and you're gonna go down the
list and every dollar has suggested
categories already in that budget so you
may could take some of those out if they
don't apply to you you can add some
and then you're gonna put dollar amounts
next to all of those categories and the
goal is your income for august
minus all of those categories including
giving and saving in your case will
equal zero
so every dollar coming in in august is
assigned to a category you know exactly
where your paycheck's going
and since you're starting out kind of at
a clean slate uh your goal really is a
thousand dollar emergency funds that's
your number one goal before paying off
debt and so you can use your budget then
to be your guide to say hey
what can i cut are there things i can
bring in extra income could i get a side
you know a side gig at night
how's the way to raise my income
and where can i cut expenses in my
budget realistically i'm not asking you
to like spend twenty dollars in food for
the month or something right you want to
be realistic about your budget um but
it's a great guide to say hey here's
where my money's going where can i cut
to get that thousand dollars quickly
and quickly anthony i mean you're you're
changing your entire life right now when
we're talking about money like if you
have not been on
any kind of system any kind of plan
this is a complete
mindset shift that you're about to
experience so things are going to be new
it's going to be uncomfortable you're
going to do things you've never done
before but that's a good thing because
you want to start winning with money
which means you're going to do things
you've never done before and so
that budget and getting that thousand
dollars that's gonna that's your first
goal and really it's kind of the thing
that i always tell people it gives you a
sense of confidence
and the budget will take about three
months to work so august will probably
be a disaster and that's okay give
yourself grace september it'll kind of
work october it's like okay buy no buy
buy christmas for sure by thanksgiving
you're gonna say okay i get it like i i
know i i feel in control and that's
gonna be able to guide you to getting
that thousand dollars and also start
working your way out of debt
i just did a lot of talking i did a lot
of talking what's your yeah what
questions do you have
no that's perfectly fine i i definitely
appreciate it um
so a couple questions i have is at the
moment i'm currently behind on
quite a bit of bills uh
my gas for my house is
about a thousand behind my car payment's
behind about a thousand
um and then i just got to get that way
anthony
what happened that didn't happen
overnight that doesn't happen one month
that's two or three or four or five
months
yeah so i have a terrible spending habit
for impulse buying okay on
pretty much every paycheck so like i'll
pay
what i think i can pay and then i'll be
like oh i have 200 left i have to have
200 left for myself
okay um for for
for random stupid stuff
do you
if i'm i'm asking you honestly and ask
you i want you to answer me honestly um
do you struggle with addiction in any
way
no no no totally clean okay all right so
this is purely
you're just not disciplined with your
money
yeah okay i'll go out and i'll buy like
a 75
air purifier or
some kind of appliance or i'll go out
and
just random stuff okay
and and when you're doing that anthony
is it because
it's exciting because you're bored
because like what's the what's the why
behind that impulse spending for you
i would feel like it's exciting because
every time i get money i'm just like oh
i have some money i can spend yeah and
then i'll just go out i'll spend it yep
and then after you spend it when you
look back now where you're sitting
all the air purifiers and all the random
stuff you spent
has it been worth it is it worth it
no not at all because then i end up
either never use it it's just a
paperweight at that point i'll use it
for about a week
that's it which is human nature by the
way everyone does that we all think if
we're going to spend money it is right
john talks about this how i do it too
how the chemicals in your brain it's
exciting your body you get a little
adrenaline and it's fun and you're like
okay okay so that happens to everyone
so for you anthony it's it's really this
moment of saying you know what i'm going
to be an adult
and there's a quote dave always says
that
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good
so there's a level anthony that it's
like you gotta you you have to be a
grown up you have to be an adult you got
to pay your bills you got to say no to
yourself even when you really really
want it
and so um on a very tactical side before
before this call gets short
is i want you to catch up on all of your
bills before anything else and so
anthony i'm gonna
really press you i want you
to get one or two extra jobs today i
want you today
like you you have to radically do
something different because if you keep
doing what you've been doing you're
gonna keep getting what you've been
getting
and so bringing in an income and then
you're cutting everything and to say you
know i i will not i will not spend on
this but you talk about this to the
behavior change aspect though so look
dude put you got to put some hurdles
between you and this impulse okay uh we
rachel i talked about on a previous show
it's the gap between stimulus and
response i'm gonna go buy this thing
i need this to i i need to go buy this
thing i need you just that that's the
gap you've got to control because that's
what's getting you in trouble what does
that mean take your debit card out of
your wallet and leave it at home
don't leave with it make your lunch and
take that to work to where that's all
you have and if you forget to take your
lunch you don't eat that day
you won't do that very many times before
you get really hungry and you start
making your lunch make peanut butter
jelly sandwiches or some beans and rice
or whatever it is to get to work
make it take get rid of amazon prime
just just delete it
make yourself have to jump through a
bunch of hoops to go spend money
and that will give you some space on
your way to jumping through all these
hoops to say what am i doing
what is my body trying to tell me what
am i trying to avoid what am i
embarrassed about what am i ashamed
about and my guess is you work real real
hard
and it's annoying to you
that you can't just go get what you want
is that fair
yeah no that's absolutely true you bust
your butt every day and you do work in
the heat and it's hot and it's hard
you're driving a forklift you've got a
skill that other people don't have
and dude i just want to thank air
purifier
and i can't afford it because i'm about
to shut my gas off
and so the the not nice way of saying
this is you are broke and you're in a
scary position
you're about to lose your home dude
right
yeah yep so as rachel said it's time to
do everything differently right
opposite how old are you anthony
opposite anthony
i'm 32 32 okay
well i'm excited for you because i
really do hang on the line austin i'll
pick up we'll give you a subscription to
ramsey plus because that adds in every
dollar in the videos but anthony i want
you to be radical i want you to do the
opposite of everything you've been doing
i want you to work like crazy and i want
you to pay your bills instead of paying
for air purifiers change